i
[Música]
en 2021 hasta fines de mayo se
registraron 143 muertes violentas de
mujeres travestis y trans en argentina
de acuerdo con un informe del
observatorio mujeres de la materia
latinoamericana de esas muertes 94
fueron femicidios en todo 2020 fueron
251 los femicidios según estadísticas de
la corte suprema- y aunque hay altibajos
en estos años nunca han sido menos que
los 236 que se registraron en 2015 ese
año tras el asesinato del adolescente
que ahora pérez a manos de su novio
nació la consigna ni una menos para
reclamar por el fin de los femicidios
ese movimiento que sigue vigente cumplió
seis años el pasado 3 de junio en todo
este tiempo se implementaron diversas
iniciativas oficiales para intentar
poner fin a este fenómeno sin embargo en
argentina los femicidios aún no terminan
de bajar ni tampoco las muchas otras
formas de violencia contra la mujer que
persisten en nuestra sociedad
[Música]
según el observatorio de la violencia de
la universidad nacional autónoma de
honduras en lo que va de este año 112
mujeres han sido asesinadas en este país
estos delitos son cometidos por sus
parejas es por ello que los defensores
de los derechos humanos exigen a las
autoridades aumentar las penas para los
que cometen este tipo de delitos
actualmente el código procesal penal
contempla penas de entre 20 y 25 años
para los femicidios sin embargo existe
una gran mora judicial según estos
mismos defensores el 96 por ciento de
estos casos no han sido judicializados
la oficina de onu-mujeres en honduras ha
pedido además fortalecer los esfuerzos
en cuanto a la prevención además
asegurar la celeridad en cuanto a las
llamadas de emergencia que llegan al 911
así como fortalecer el instituto
nacional de la mujer para ofrecer ayuda
monetaria y psicológica a las víctimas
[Música]
en mexico en lo que va del año son 311
feminicidios los que se tienen
contabilizados oficialmente un delito
que de acuerdo con el propio gobierno
federal no ha logrado reducirse en el
país desatando las incontables protestas
del movimiento feminista que ha
irrumpido también en la arena política
en el actual proceso electoral
impulsando la regla 3 de 3 para evitar
que llegue a un cargo público cualquier
hombre que haya incurrido ya sea en
agresión sexual incluyendo hostigamiento
y acoso en violencia contra la mujer en
el ámbito público o privado o que sea
deudor de pensión alimenticia las
mujeres agrupadas en el colectivo
ciudadano todas mx han denunciado 100
candidaturas que incurren en al menos
uno de estos tres delitos contra la
mujer en el actual proceso electoral
[Música]